I keep clicking the stop video button when I click back to zoom.
What?
Don't turn your video off.
It's like you've gone off in a huff, John.
I can't believe you said that Liz.
Okay, that was a bit of a visual joke.
Hello, everyone.
And welcome to the very 83rd episode of Octa Thorpe, a broadcast for Science Fiction and
Science Fiction fandom, which is coming to you on the 11th of May 2023.
And King Charles has got his crown on.
I'm John Coxon.
I'm Alison Scott.
And I'm Ms. Batty.
Did you guys enjoy the coronation?
Probably.
We're recording this one.
Immediately after we recorded episode 82 because we have a load of stuff to talk about
about Eastercon and so on.
But we couldn't do any of that because we were too busy talking about the Hugo nominations
in time for you to illuminate.
So I spent the correlation playing board games.
Right then we have letters of comment.
We don't have letters of comment on last episode because of what Alison just said, but we do
have a letters of comment on the two episodes from before that.
So strap in.
First up, we have a letter of comment from Raj who says that he strongly agrees with me
that Digger is excellent and did point out that I hadn't put the link in the show notes
but I have fixed that now.
He has a hard copy, which is the omnibus that So For Wolf press did years back and it is
a beast of a book.
And I have not got a hard copy, but I can imagine that it's quite big.
Can you?
Yes.
This.
Um, maybe to say, uh, thank you to everyone who watched us live at Eastercon and left
comment and to those who watched us live and then listened to the actual podcast, which
I think is going above and beyond.
Thank you to Fran who left us a letter of comment.
And I think this might be a new one.
She left us a letter of comment in the discord thread for our item on the Eastercon discord.
And she's basically off to give her Captain Dreamies via the medium of interpretive dance,
which is another way of giving us a letter of comment.
I would also like to say thank you to everyone who made our item at conversation, the one
with the most discord comments.
I don't think this is a reflection of the engagement with the item so much as a our listeners
like to back channel a bunch of shit battles in the discord and also that we did start
about half an hour late.
So they had to really entertain themselves.
Johnny Badley also watched live and then listened to the podcast afterwards.
So yeah, that is a is dedication.
I mean, I didn't do that.
There was some serious discussion about looking at the amount of engagement on the discord
as a measure of how good program items were and guys don't do that.
Our program item was the best program item.
We have the most comments on the discord of any item at conversation by a factor of
about three, I think.
The other thing about the live thing is at the end of it, it just kind of finished and
then they turned off my zoom and I was like, oh, that means I don't get to say goodbye
to John and Liz and Liz is going back to Thailand because immediately now I am going
to get in a car, get in a playground car and drive back to London.
But neither of the other two people in the car got the plague.
So there you go.
But I didn't get to say goodbye.
So bye bye, chaps.
Bye Alison.
We also heard from Ispania Sherif who let us know that there is a D&D TV series in the
works in which Joe Mangenello is adapting the Dragonlance series to TV, which we now
know was a formative book series for both Neil Harrison and Adrian Tricovsky.
So, yeah, interesting stuff.
He's also working on a documentary.
He is a massive nerd.
It's good.
I like it.
Farah Mendelssohn wrote to say that we can't hold the Eastcon in Wales because we can't
find a suitable venue, which I think is something that most people agree.
And she also says that Telford is the main convention venue for Wales.
Welsh people write in.
I remember the Chester Eastcon.
I wish we could go back to Chester.
That was a great venue.
Chester is also not a primary convention venue for Wales.
I'd better than Telford.
But in terms of being in Wales.
If there is a spectrum of Welshness, Chester is more Welsh than Telford.
Yeah.
I suspect that's just angered Welsh people and Chester people.
So that's good.
So we have a letter of coin from James Shields about Plan Z.
And we mentioned this in episode 80.
He confirms that it is a fork of Zambia.
And he does note, for a while, I've felt that naming your project after an African country
might be culturally insensitive.
That is a fair thing to point out that we did not cover at the end of episode 80.
There is a GitHub for Plan Z and listener to the show.
Andrew January has created a GitHub issue to suggest changing the name away from Plan
Z.
And we will put a link to that issue in the show notes if you want to contribute.
There are some other names being suggested and whatnot.
If I had known there was a GitHub repo for Plan Z, I would have gone and raised an issue
myself but I did not know.
So thank you to Andrew for telling us.
Yes, Z Graves has suggested the name Ariadne because it weaves a lot of threads together.
And I super like that.
Plus it supports our spider theme.
More spiders in science fiction, please.
On the subject of spiders in science fiction, Esther McCum Stewart wrote in to tell us that
there will be a spider's track at Glasgow in 2024.
There will also be one about Armadillos and Wondervoted to Badger and collectively the
Badger Armadillo and spiders tracks will be called all about that BAS which is an incredibly
tortured joke that I loved.
Thank you very much Esther.
Very good.
Chris Garcia wrote to us on the 31st of March.
And he says it was another good episode.
And notes that there has been small scale octopus farming for centuries by his tribe.
You'd find corals of Thornwood, Redwood and Oak brought in tiny bays that would keep
them in pens.
They used a lasso to catch them and dumped them in there.
The Oak is sturdy, the Thornwood prickly and the Redwood full of tannins that octopus
don't much care for.
They also supposedly penned in dolphins but they don't get residuals from SeaWorld.
That is a horrific thing to tell us.
Thank you very much Chris.
Yeah, there's a difference between kind of trappings of wild octopus behind plants they
don't like and having a massive Chinese octopus farm, right?
The Chinese octopus farm of course being in Spain.
Famous for its Chinese farms, Spain.
He also notes if the third row panel isn't held with all the participants sitting in
the third row, then we all are leaving money on the table.
As Andrew Hogg has said, many a time, the third row isn't a place.
If a third row are sits in a row, that row is the third row.
And so it shall always be.
One of the best lines in the third row panel was Mark Plummer pointing out that in that
same third row where third row fandom was formed, Peter Mayby was sitting who was 78
at the time.
So we have known Peter Mayby was in third row fandom.
He doesn't respond to our emails but he is more than welcome.
Peter, if you're listening, there's a discord.
Chengdu is a shower segment.
Sunny spells this week, not much showering is occurring.
I would say I did have a chat to Fran Tuscalo Verso at Eastercom who I think is helping
out in some ways on programme for Chengdu and it all sounded pretty good actually.
I was delighted that Sandra Bond, who was one of the candidates that I nominated, is
going to be the TAF delegate to Pemokon in Winnipeg in August.
So Pemokon is the NASFIC and I think the Sondras will be an extra-lit delegate and I
was very pleased to see her win.
And I hope that Nikolai will run again because he had a lot of support in Europe and I think
also could do with making more collections in the US to pick up North American votes there.
Yeah, is it Nikolai's third loss?
I think it's second.
Second, sorry second.
So I don't know.
I feel so if anyone who runs twice and loses both times and I hope they will run again.
I think there might be, oh I'm trying to think of a way of saying this, that he is,
to lose once is sad.
To lose twice might mean you need to change your North American nominators to people who
will actually get your vote out.
I am sure the people that Michelage picked were great but I would maybe, I mean, Chris
Garcia, he's very good at getting people to vote for people, like considering him an email.
There are merits in choosing your nominators carefully in the territory you're less well
known in.
That wasn't very diplomatic but yes.
For a race where the final date was the day after Esterkon, Sondra chose three European
nominators who were all on the Esterkon committee.
Yeah, we'll also say Sandra's selection of nominators was, sorry Sandra, terrible because
you're basically choosing three people who all appeal to the same.
Oh thanks a lot.
Oh no, I mean but you want to choose three people who will appeal to different demographics,
not three people who are all in the same group of people.
So yes, I think that's one area where Michelage did better because he had a much wider range
of European nominators.
But Sandra won so, you know, hindsight is irrelevant.
Sandra did pick at least one nominator who went round every single person at Corfloo going,
have you voted in tap yet?
They're not leaving until they either said yes or went and did it so that will have helped.
But I mean when you say you should pick your North American nominators very carefully,
I think it's possible that Sandra's nominators, John DeBary and Ted White, also kind of appeal
to a similar constituency, right?
I mean maybe that is it.
Oh yeah, but Sandra is incredibly well known in North America fandom.
Okay.
The point is you need to make sure, so like I did a blog post, this is getting slightly
into the weeds, but I did a blog post after the 2013 race where I broke down how many
of the votes for Jim Moett came from, because you, you, when you get the votes as the administrator
in the old days, it would have on the bottom what, where the form came from because you
were still getting PDFs of forms.
And it became very clear that over half of the votes that were submitted had been distributed
by Randy Byitz.
And so picking an administrator who works to get the vote out gets you, and if you get
someone who's good at it, gets you a lot of votes.
And it's one of those things where I know in British fandom we like to pretend that campaigning
doesn't help, but campaigning really helps.
So you've got to, you've got to make sure that you've picked people who will campaign
and campaign hard.
This is also why when Warren Buff ran in 2010, I can't remember when, but a while back
2012, he picked Paul Cornell, which I remember thinking was a weird choice because I think
there were some people who were put off by the fact he had picked a pro, but also I
could not in any way imagine Paul Cornell wandering around in East con nagging people
to vote.
It does not seem like a poor thing to do in any way.
So yeah, I think there's an arts picking people who are bullshit and who will.
Yes, I don't think I nagged anyone at least, gone to vote.
No, well, if, if I had been, if I had been Sandra, I would have picked someone who was
not working in East con to go with you and, and one of the other two perhaps, but, um.
So what, what I find interesting in a way is how swingy the vote totals are in taff.
Oh, yeah.
And this was definitely one of our lower, lower numbered ones, but it's interesting
on how they kind of swing from over 200, kind of under 100.
And I thought at first it might be on the direction of the race.
More people vote in the races that are sending US nominees to the UK, your EU than the other
way, but actually it's not.
It's just though, obviously there's some people who are really getting out the vote, or maybe
it's related to the number of people who run in the race because you all like mobilise
the same small set of people.
But yeah, it is interesting.
Maybe I will dig into this further for a future episode.
Yeah, I think, I think it is definitely true.
I mean, they say definitely.
I strongly suspect that it's true that that if you have active nominators, the vote total
goes up quite considerably.
Like when Liam ran against, when Liam and Graham Charnock ran in 2011 against me, like
Liam had like 80 voters just in Europe because he was so like on it, but he did not have
the North American strength to pull it through.
Also Liam, if you're listening, we hope you recover fully and quickly.
Yeah, no.
I don't think he is listening, but yes, if he is.
Sorry, Liam.
And then the EFF, or F. F.
EFF can't be confused with anything else.
Right?
No, but the European Fan Fund was one.
By the children of Chitska.
Congratulations to them and Commiserations to James Shields, who ran and didn't really
want to win, I don't think, but wanted the race to happen and wanted it to be contested.
So yes, but they will visit conflict, which is in of Salah in Sweden in June.
And we didn't get an awful lot of votes for it.
So I think, I mean, it's just not surprising given that it was a new fund, but I think
we'd like to see some more enthusiasm for this for next time, because I do think it's
a great idea.
It will get some help because it's getting 20% of the Fan Fund's raised at conversation,
which spoiler is an enormous amount of money.
So that's quite good.
I think this is a good lesson about how, although hybrid conventions are great, they might not
be very good at getting Fan Fund votes out.
Because I think if Marcin had been on site at Eastcon, maybe he could have done some more
wandering around, encouraging people to vote.
And also if the person at Eastcon was the person in the race who didn't want to win
as much, maybe he did less campaigning than he might have done.
So I think what we probably need.
And was also quite busy?
Yes, I was also quite busy.
So what you probably want is a British or Irish fan to run who wants to win, and is that
Eastcon, if your deadline is going to be just after Eastcon, because that will help get
votes in.
Yeah, or you could have the sort of British fans who get the vote out for these things,
not actually also running the Eastcon, also good things.
So next year I think we'll get more votes out.
Hopefully because the contributions from the voting fees, because there are only 33
voters, the voting fees are about 200 quid when I did all the conversions.
Because it turns out 353 Polish.
So T is not a huge amount of money in pounds.
So I think they will have to try and get the vote out of it, because it's probably not
sustainable to run a fan fund on kind of that plus 20% of a fan fund auction revenue.
I think there's money basically.
Moshy's very relaxed about having operating funds for this at the moment.
And also maybe we'll get TAP reports or things.
I mean, I've still quite lost a SUS TAP report, and I'm going to sell a lot more.
So that does actually, it's going to be a useful amount of money for TAF.
Shall we talk about the Eastcon?
We've kind of already started talking about Eastcon.
So that's good.
But yeah, shall we do that some more?
Yeah, there was an Eastcon.
And we're doing the elephant in the room first or last.
It's the Og to Thorpe COVID policy round up.
Yee-haw.
A lot of people caught COVID at Eastcon.
We started counting, but we stopped counting when it was obvious it was going to be enormous
numbers.
I mean, it doesn't really matter what you get up above about 80 cases.
It's like, oh, yes, loads of cases, which it was.
Yeah, I mean, I did my own personal mini count based on what I could see on Discord,
Facebook and Twitter, and I got somewhere over 100.
But yeah, I guess when your question is, do we give it to 10% of the convention or 15%
of the convention?
OK, you know, maybe that's not a big, a big issue.
A lot of people caught COVID at conversation.
I would prefer that we did not use the phrase how many people did we give COVID to?
We didn't give COVID to anybody.
A lot of people caught it that weekend.
I'll just leave all of that in.
And I'm sure that'll be fine.
I'm completely fine with that.
Because, you know, it's a lot of different things.
And people, I hope that we did tell people if you come to a convention where we put 800
people in a hotel weekend, there's a good chance you're going to get COVID.
Because I think we did say that fairly clearly.
You know, that's why we had a hybrid program where you didn't need to come to the convention
if you didn't want to catch an illness.
We knew it was going to be quite high number because last year, by the close of Monday of
the Eastcon, we'd had five reports.
And this year, by the 10 o'clock committee meeting on Monday morning, we had had 28
reports.
So, you know, a lot.
Yes.
I believe.
So I caught COVID and Alison caught COVID and Liz did not catch COVID.
Did you catch COVID, John?
I got COVID.
I tested positive on Monday last week.
So I suspect I got it.
I don't think I got it at the convention.
I either got it from a Spaniard or I got it when I went home to visit my parents.
It would be hilariously bad luck if I avoided it at the Eastcon and got it on a trained
Peterborough while fully masked, but there you are.
But it's very mild.
If I hadn't tested, if a Spaniard hadn't had it, I would not have tested.
I had a very vaguely sore throat.
But yes, a Spaniard got it with the unfortunate, there's an unfortunate side effect, which
is that a Spaniard has decided, I think, that future Eastcons without mask mandates will
not be a thing she comes to.
So that might mean I am not at them either, which makes me slightly sad.
I was hoping that despite being quite convinced this would end up being a rather large incidence
of COVID, I was hoping I was wrong.
And I am very sad I was not wrong.
And yeah, I haven't quite processed that yet because I've been to every Eastcon since
2007 and it will be weird to break that streak.
But that's that.
That's how the cookie crumbles.
My wife's thresholds are clearly in a different place from the communities.
And that's just something I have to sort of process in my own time.
I think there's a wide range of views in the community because there's definitely people
who are there with you.
The problem is we'd have had a lot of COVID at that convention, even if we'd had a full
mask mandate.
We wouldn't have had as much, definitely.
But we wouldn't have mandated masking in the hotel bar or in the breakfast room of the
hotel.
We couldn't have done or in the Hilton's executive lounge or the swimming pool.
And there was spread in all of those cases that we know about.
As I said before, as I said in the episode before the convention, it's all about shifting
the probability distribution to the left where you can.
And there were things the Eastcon could have done to shift it to the left that they chose
not to, which I understand.
And as I say, my thresholds are in a different place from the communities clearly.
But that does mean that it has an effect on my future congoing.
And I'm not going to pretend it doesn't.
You know, I am cognizant of the fact that it's not designed around me and my experience.
And that's right and proper.
But it does mean in this instance that I am going to be one of the ones that don't come
to as many in-person conventions.
And that makes me deeply, deeply sad, like really sad.
But there's nothing I can do about it other than other than argue.
But I tried that and it doesn't work.
So now it's time to get used to it, I think.
Well, I think far as planning to tighten up the mask mandate for levitation.
But I will have to be at levitation because I'm doing a big job for Glasgow that will
mandate my being there.
But I have no interest in spending my own money to go to events that do have mask mandates.
So, you know.
No, yeah, I mean, that's it, right?
You have won and I have lost.
But it does feel very much like I have lost.
I don't think I have won because I think levitation is going to tighten up.
And I think I'll have to go there anyway.
But if that becomes the way, if Eastercons decide that masking to prevent people from
getting very mild sore throats is the way they're going, then, I mean, obviously, people
can mask if they like.
I think that's completely fine.
I don't want to have a problem that says in program items, you mask.
But I do have a problem that says in all conventional spaces, you mask.
So, you know, because I like seeing my friends smile and I'm happy to see them smile online,
which is something I do every day.
I would just say, ispania has been mostly unconscious for about a week because it has
completely exhausted her.
So it's not just that she got a very mild sore throat.
And that's the problem.
You don't know in advance.
I mean, eventually everyone has to have it for the first time, right?
Because it's a cold, it's going to spread into the system of diseases like all other
coronaviruses have.
I say, well, we don't know that.
I don't think we can say this is a bunch of very mild sore throats because, yes, if
it was the only effect of COVID or you've got a very mild sore throat, then yes, I think
it would be different.
But we know there's a spectrum of, you know, very mild sore throats through to, you know,
still serious disease and ongoing serious disease.
So I don't think it's, I don't think it's very sensible also to say, oh, well, eventually
it'll be like a coronavirus or like the other coronaviruses because we don't know it will.
And we also have no idea how long that might take.
So we'll come back on October 3,027 to see how that all went.
I would say personally that while I knew there was a risk of COVID at EasterCon, the
numbers were shockingly high even to me.
When you say, you know, there was transmission going, I don't think you can say where transmission
happened.
I mean, yes, obviously the breakfast room on the bar were poorly ventilated and full
of people close together.
But what I think is like, is there a middle ground we can do which is make it possible
for people to attend and enjoy the convention without putting themselves at risk while still
allowing people who want to do the risky things to do them?
And I think my attitude is still that, you know, you could draw a line which was make
it possible for people to go into basically say masks in program space, mass in the dealer's
room, mass in the arch, or mass in those spaces and have a mask, a mandatory mass social space.
And then basically inform people there won't be anything in the bar or the hotel breakfast.
And then people can make that choice, I think, to know that they'll be able to go to program
or if their dealers to come and deal at the convention and know that people will be wearing
masks around them and it gives them a level of protection.
Some people may still say this is not enough and they still wouldn't come.
Some people will say that's unpleasant, they don't want to sit in program in mass all day
and do it.
But it feels like that's a middle ground between the two extremes.
We obviously can't plead both extremes so maybe I'm going from middle ground where we
try and plead someone.
And maybe that's no good, maybe it's better to go for one or the other.
But that would be my current feeling about it.
I'm asked as a dealer in the dealer's room last year where you're masking continuously
for eight hours doing that.
And I found it extremely unpleasant because you have to talk to people, you have to gauge
in them with them and that's really quite hard through a mask all day.
I think I'd definitely be up for, well, we ask people going to the dealer's room and
art show to mask but I'm not convinced that we should mandate masking for the dealers and
artists so that's a thing.
It's complicated but we have a lot of convention spaces that weren't dealers room or...
I feel very strongly, it's been you being unable to work for a week, is less of an...
more of an inconvenience than someone having to wear a mask for six hours.
I think what I find the most frustrating is the...
There seems to be an implicit assumption in the discussion that wearing a mask is equally
unpleasant to having COVID and I find that exhausting because I don't think that's true.
No, it's not.
Definitely worse having COVID.
Even by COVID this time, which was much, much less bad than the other time or possible
other two times.
I don't enjoy wearing a mask but I don't enjoy having COVID either.
And I know which one I prefer.
I think there's a...
I think what a lot of people would like to be able to do is not wear a mask and not get
COVID and I think those people are clearly very big fans of the fantasy genre.
So don't think it works.
And so I think you have to decide would I rather have COVID or would I rather have the
inconvenience wearing a mask and I am surprised by how many people seem to be on the other
side of that argument to me.
But again, like, I respect that.
It just...
It catches me unawares.
Okay, you've got quite a lot of people on your side.
There's quite a lot of public statements saying, "Oh, we would like this to be quite a lot
of strong.
We've had quite a lot of email.
This is a...
I know this is a lurker support me in email thing but when we ask for feedback, which will
pass to levitation, quite a lot of the feedback is saying, "We think you struck quite a good
balance and it's not your fault everyone got COVID."
I'm not sure I agree with that.
I think we're far enough after the convention now that I would say that although I was...
I wasn't involved in the discussion of what I polish you should be because dead parents.
But I was happy to go along with the result in order in terms of communicating it and
letting people know, "I think if people have followed our COVID policy, we'd have had less
COVID."
But they didn't, which is a thing to say.
No, I want to push back on this, right, because I have heard you said this a few times.
We did tell you in advance what the result of your COVID policy would be on this very
podcast.
Oh yeah, you were right.
I want to say this on record on the podcast.
You were right about that.
Thank you.
Well, hang on, let me just bask.
Sorry, you were right about that.
You told us it wouldn't work and you were right.
I also want to say because it's now a month after the convention or something, my personal
view was that we should have had a stronger COVID policy with mandatory masking in program
spaces and mandatory masking in corridors in convention spaces.
And mandatory masking in the green room, which I think was another place where we know COVID
spread quite a lot.
And we think it's very likely COVID spread quite a lot.
Masking in the green room would have been very difficult.
It's hard.
Yes.
Because you would have needed, it was already quite difficult for people on Zoom to hear
people through the laptops that had been set up on the tables in the green rooms.
So for those who weren't at the convention, it was hybrid, obviously, and that meant that
some of the panels had remote participants.
And so each room, each program room in the hotel had a corresponding table in the green
room, which had the laptop for the virtual green room for that program room on that table.
And so when you went to green room, you had your table, which was your item, and then
the laptop had the virtual people.
And I would have to probably think quite carefully about like ambient noise and microphones
if you wanted that to work, which isn't to say it couldn't work, but this is moving
a little bit away from COVID.
But that was the most experimental part of our hybrid design.
And we doubled the size of the green room on Saturday afternoon, open brackets after
the horse had bolted, close brackets.
But we should have had a twice as big a green room in the first place and not doing so was
a mistake for lots of reasons, including the hybrid element screen room.
Do you want to say things about COVID before I talk more about green room?
Because I have more ideas about green room lists, but they're not really COVID based.
Yeah, let's I think when we talk a bit more about hybrid and so on, we should talk about
that.
I mean, I think my thoughts are covered out.
We're going to keep having this conversation.
I would say that bear in mind that if you collect feedback directly after the convention
when, you know, maybe 120 of your members are quite ill, you may not get the, you know,
unbiased feedback.
I think we're going to keep discussing it, but I think we need to also remember that
masks are not the 100% solution or the only solution and be thinking about other ways
we do things like the ventilation in the bar was definitely poor.
This was one of those cases where I may have appreciated what some hotels do where they
shove all the con people in a separate breakfast room, because maybe, maybe that would have
been better.
I certainly put a mask on when I go up to get my breakfast from the breakfast buffet.
And this is partly because I've been trained to in hotels where that is mandatory.
But also it's quite nice.
I'm not, you know, speeding like spit all over your like bacon eggs.
You know, it seems like quite a nice thing to do.
So maybe that should be thing people do.
And for those who want that service, subscribe to Liz only fans.
But yeah, I think we've got to take all that into account.
We also got to think about, you know, better ventilation, what we can do maybe as a set
of Easter cons, try and encourage that.
I will say one place that I think conversation couldn't have known this, but it was true.
It was a very big space called the refectory with lots of chairs and tables spread out
quite a lot where you could take food and drink and socialize.
And it was really underused and then everyone was crammed in the main bar.
So maybe if you did have a fan bar, a bit like reclamation's where you had people spread
out and they could get beer there, it might encourage people to just spread out a bit.
But you know, I think this is a, this is an evolving thing.
But I think we do need to think about it because I mean, I personally am thinking, okay,
I had a very nice time.
I don't regret coming to Eastcon.
If I had got COVID, it could have been really disastrous.
I could have been stuck in a hotel for a week.
I could have had canceled flights.
You know, I could, I'm really, it does make me rethink whether I want to attend food
Easter cons, unfortunately, because of the risk of disease and because of the risk of
like, like, disruptive disruption to my life.
So I think the numbers basically are, if they stay this high, it will be hard to justify
it more than occasionally.
Yeah, we had the refectory.
We probably could have done a lot more to say to people.
This is a large, airy ventilated space because our program rooms were all very well ventilated
that you could go and eat food and drink and chat to your friends.
And it's going to be safer than the bar.
I mean, I don't know if it was safe for the bar, but I think it probably was.
And then we also had a bus required lounge, which wasn't used at all.
But no, I don't know whether we talked about that before, but like the other part of the
problem is, I'm going to go to where my friends are.
I'm not going to sit in the mask required bar and hope my friends come to me.
So that is tricky.
I wanted to say, what did I want to say?
This is, it's weird, I think, how much of these discussions are?
There are things we've been asking for as a convention for ages.
Like when the fan bar and the actual bar are opposite ends of the hotel, like before
the pandemic, we were like, oh, why aren't they closer together?
It's such a pain that if someone was a gin and tonic, they have to be at this end of
the hotel, but someone was really allowed to be there in the hotel.
I can't be in the same place.
And then we finally cracked that issue and like, why can't we have breakfast with all
of the normal people with the nice breakfast instead of being in a little ghetto?
We've cracked that issue and other pandemics happened to be like, why can't, why can't
we be in our little ghetto and why can't the real little be the other side of the hotel?
It's so unfair.
And so that just occurs to me, it's like, you know, it's like the, someone's clearly
made a wish on a monkey paw for these things that has gone badly.
So if that was you, write in.
Before we go off COVID, we're about to go off COVID, right?
So we haven't said the keyword.
I would not like to be the levitation chair right now.
Hello, Farrah.
No, it'll be a tricky job.
Because you've got a lot of work collecting all these different points of view together
and ending up with something that works.
You should do a survey.
To a survey, have like at scales.
I love a good survey.
Yeah, levitation.
Do a survey.
Ask your members what they actually think and do it in a way that means that it won't,
their personal views will not be made public or get back to people who can harangue them
a lot on the internet because there's some very harangue people on both sides of the
document.
I think it may be time for a survey.
I'm just going to say I don't think it should just be levitation members because obviously
there will be people who aren't joining levitation for that reason.
But you probably don't want it to be completely open.
But we have surveyed EasterCon members before in the future of EasterCon surveys.
It might be time to do something like that.
You're not going to guarantee it will change your positions, but it would be interesting
to know how many people fall into which different set of opinions.
I do love that we have people on both sides of this argument in this podcast.
I think it would be very sad if I never saw John as a convention again, but you know,
adcope.
Would you wear a mask if it meant you would see John as a convention?
I see John at times other than conventions.
But I am just going to say the other thing that would change a lot of this is if you could
get a COVID booster from boots and you could get it in late February because my attitude
towards a lot of this would change drastically if I could reliably get a booster three weeks
before the convention.
I do very unsafe things at Novicon every year and I have not caught COVID at Novicon and
that's because I always have my boot booster in October.
Novicon's a month later.
It's fine.
I would like to have a second booster about the before Easter card and not only would
I get one but I get to lots of people.
I'd probably be sicker with the booster than I was with COVID this time, but at least I
wouldn't worry that I was infecting all my friends.
When you can plan it then, it's quite nice because we had to, Mike was near a gig and
I was like, we'll be able to go to that because if we do get COVID, we'll have recovered by
the time that happens.
But then I ended up testing seven days after the convention positive and then I had skipped
the gig.
I was incredibly irritating.
So boo.
I've got to be honest.
That's the other thing, right?
Like if next year there is a Mike Wozniak gig within a week of Eastercon.
I might like Mike Wozniak's mustache more than I like Eastercon.
You can quote me on that.
It was spectacularly inconvenient for me catching COVID at Eastercon.
Mary-Ann also caught COVID and had to delay the start date of her job.
So, you know, that is a pain in the ass.
It's a very brief plug.
So, I mean, I have no way of actually properly assessing this or not.
But I bought a nasal spray with like one of these things that like, just put stuff in
your nasal mucus and puts, you know, antibodies up there or whatever.
Like one of these boots, like the, you know, boots, dual-defencing, it's like that.
It's also got anti-COVID antibodies in there.
And I don't know if it made a difference or not, but it was not like horrible to do.
And it was 15 quid and I put it up my nostrils twice a day and I was definitely sitting around
chatting with people who got COVID and I did not get COVID.
So I think that will be part of my like regimen for future events, to be honest.
Oh, I'm 100% up for that.
Sounds good.
Can't buy it.
It's Thailand only.
I'll bring you about all next time.
I want to talk very quickly about the green room.
This is one area where I think the way that conversation did green room made me think
that you could have done with a lot of tiny rooms like they have at the park in and he
throw because then you could have a tiny, you could have a green room per room.
And that would be quite good for stopping spread.
I don't know.
And the problem is with conference centers.
So I don't know whether this will work for levitation or for reconnect, which is the 2025
Belfast EATCOM because they're both convention center EATCOMs.
But like if you did have a lot of rooms that were too small to be useful, having different
green rooms in them, if you were going to use the same model as conversation might potentially
be a good way of doing things.
I mean, it might also not be, but it was just a thought I had.
It's a bit of a funny pain for the green room stuff because to tell if people are actually
there, you can't check them in.
You need that entry gate really.
Yeah.
I think we should have a hundred percent virtual green room.
I think the green room is an enormous faff and that people should just join in or log in
on a zoom and have a chat.
I cannot successfully overstate how much I disagree with that.
No, so okay.
So I think the green room, I think there are three reasons I disagree.
I will now enumerate them.
Reason one, log in onto a zoom.
I didn't log on to the zoom during the convention and that adds a layer of things I have to
worry about.
But I'm glad I didn't have to worry about and I was glad that I could if I needed to,
but I was equally glad I didn't have to.
Second thing is I really like, I really like having like my drink sorted before going to
the panel rather than having it delivered to the room the panel is happening in.
So that I think would suffer a little bit.
But thirdly, I quite like getting the vibe of my fellow panelists off stage before being
on the panel with them, especially if it's on, I don't know very well.
I kind of like being able to feel them out a bit.
I wouldn't have liked, especially, I'm not going to plug the Adrian Tchaikovsky interview
against Ory listeners, but especially when I met Adrian Tchaikovsky for the first time,
I'm glad that that like initial feeling each other out about the interview didn't happen
virtually because I think doing it in person was probably a better way to get ready for
the panel.
So those are some unformed thoughts about that.
But it's definitely an idea.
I hope that wasn't too strident.
So yeah, I think the green room was very experimental.
I hope we do more hybrid.
I think hybrid was a huge success for this gone.
Yep.
I love the way that on the Friday morning everyone was like, oh, this item has a disembodied
face coming in, that's weird, and by Monday everyone was like, oh, no, we've got a couple
of virtual things that it was just part of what happened at the Eastcon and I think
that's quite good.
So props to JT, who has worked incredibly hard for 18 months, making this happen.
I tell you what, JT's sad nod in the Eastcon Live episode.
I really wish there'd been a camera on JT because that was one of the funniest.
I didn't see his sad nod, so you'll have to describe it to me.
You said on your big screen of doom, like I think JT's the tech lead for Glasgow if
he is Kenny Wave, or maybe I said if you are Kenny Wave, and he just did the sadest nod
in the entire world and it was incredibly funny.
He always has at least one hilarious interjection in Octatore Live episodes Eastcon.
So that's good.
It's a good tradition.
Yeah.
So I mean, are we talking virtual?
We can do.
This is a thing.
The question did virtual really, really well.
I know there were a few teething problems and maybe people who turned up to their virtual
green rooms a bit like Cough Allison.
Oh, I had a massive, massive problem getting on.
So that was an unforeseen situation where he had to suddenly add in a Zoom stream that
was not previously planned.
But basically, it seemed to go really, really well.
Now I think now we know it can be done that well.
I would feel much more confident about trying to do an Eastercon purely virtually because
honestly, I thought it would be either like some streams I could watch, but they would
occasionally crash or they wouldn't quite work on Friday afternoon or, you know, they
wouldn't be seen as everything would be delayed.
Like now I know it can be done and they look great and the panelists managed to join.
There's no problems with missing panelists and things.
I would be much more likely to feature a response virtually because I know it may work.
And so I don't know if conversation just, I don't know whether you just didn't promote
it in places I could see it or whether you were still a little bit wary of promoting it
too heavily.
But I saw a lot of, oh, there will be lots of hybrid stuff.
But if it was like, you will be able to see everything except maybe the Lego room and
it will all be streaming and it will be live and you can ask questions in Discord and it
will be brilliant then might have got like slightly more people joining virtually.
I mean, I think that was always our vision, right?
You don't want to say we're going to do this thing that nobody else has come anywhere close
to too hard in case it's a disaster.
I'm incredibly proud of what we achieved.
You guys were both at the convention in person all of the time.
So you won't know that the Discord was also absolutely exactly what I hoped a convention
Discord would be and Andrew and Emily January take a huge amount of credit for making that
happen.
And of course, the Discord started early.
We got over half the convention onto the Discord before the convention started, which is part
of our vision.
And then it carried on until the end of the catch up.
I don't know whether that will have happened or not by the time this episode drops for
reasons, but it might have happened.
So it actually does that thing and I'm going to claim some visionary bit for this.
My vision that the Discord should surround and envelop the cons so that you have that
sense of being part of it before it starts, especially if you're new, and you have that
sense of it supporting the catch up for the convention.
But it was also good.
People who came to the convention virtually felt that they were engaged socially with
the convention as well as by watching the streaming, which was another part of what
I very much hoped would happen.
I do just want to say that even though I was at the convention in me space, I did be on
the Discord.
I think any even purely meet space conventions should have good Discords because even if
you're not attending at all hybridly or virtually, I think having a strong Discord is just such
a boon.
I would agree with that, but there is an issue for large conventions, which is that we manually
gate them.
We believe it's possible to run an automatic gate into Discord because obviously Patreons
and so on do it.
And James Shields is having a think about that at Andrew January, but unless we can
get an automatic gate, we can't manage this for say the Worldcon.
We'll need to use another less good solution.
I mean, I think we can have an automatic gate.
James and Andrew, if you're listening, I'd be interested in being in that working group
trying to do that automatically.
I am concerned that Worldcon is considering single sign-on solutions and certainly as
at the last time I looked at them, they were all still appalling.
Chicon's use of air meat was dreadful and I think we need to do better and Discord is
the obvious way to do it.
And I feel like, you know, obviously this may be all sorted by next year.
All threads for program items are amazingly good.
They are the best thing, even if it's not octa-thorp and you have 310 people posting
memes and taking the piss.
But I mean, you know, serious Discord threads are also great.
Even if you can't do automatic onboarding, which thing you can, the other thing you could
do is manually add people to a read-only Discord like a year and a half out because that is
also possible.
It's less elegant, but it is possible.
Yes, but then you have to moderate your Discord for a year and a half.
No, no, read-only.
You can give everyone a role that lets them see one channel they can't post in and that
is entirely possible.
It would be less good though.
Okay, yep.
Glasgow, if you're listening to this, I am happy to manually gate everybody into your
Discord a year and a half out along the lines that John suggests.
I mean, can you choose a better time period to do it because if you do it year and a half
out, a bunch of people are going to change their email addresses, forget the Discord
logins, you know, before the com, but not like now.
It would be much better to have an automatic solution.
It did seem to me that the kind of Discord plus Zoom plus whatever Magic JT was doing
to stream to hidden YouTube streams was the best way of doing it.
I mean, I guess it had the problem that you could in theory send people the links to
the YouTube streams because they weren't actually gated.
But it did seem to work better than AirMe.
I mean, the main issue with it was just actually getting people logged on because they don't
think James Shields' registration system is actually designed for that.
Yeah, there was a bug in the registration.
What we should have done with the great evidence of high-sized is if we'd had a couple of
streaming items a couple of weeks before the convention, the same way that we opened the
Discord.
If we said also check that your streaming system works by logging on as streaming this test
item, we'd have got a lot of people in through that and we would have, it probably wouldn't
be all of them, but we'd have identified the bug in the registration system that meant
that we ended up with a 10-step process in time that we could sort it out because by
the time we did realize we had a problem, the convention had started and we couldn't
possibly have implemented a fix.
Are you suggesting some kind of testing of software is a good thing?
The other thing I wanted to say on virtual is that the one area that we fell down was
face-to-face socials like Zoom socials because we were hoping that that would happen through
the Discord AV tables and it just didn't.
And I would like, that's something that I think you do need to put a volunteer into
early to make happen and people designing future hybrid conventions need to put a bit
more energy into that particular element of things which slightly surprised me.
I thought that once we had virtual things that encouraged people to use them, that would
be enough, but it wasn't.
What were you hoping that people would just sort of sit at a virtual table in the hope
that someone else might come along to chat to them at the virtual table?
I thought that a few people would.
That has worked at some cons.
But I don't think you had enough purely, if you weren't a virtual member, then you were
probably in the refetri or the bar or maybe somewhere slightly better ventilation.
I don't think you had enough people in the right time zone to make that work because
remember a lot of your hybrid attendees, if I was hybrid, I'm not turning up to the bar
at the bar times because I'm asleep.
So I just think, yeah, I don't know, it seems incredibly optimistic to think that this will
self-organise itself. I think just a kind of like, "This is our morning Zoom social,
this is our evening Zoom social," would have probably worked.
Yeah, I mean, we had a couple of cafe mooses and they went quite well as hybrids.
So yeah.
Yeah, but mooses already got people, basically people who know how Zoom socials work and
kind of, you know, I mean, I guess maybe most people do by now, but yeah, I still think
you need a bit of like, hand-holding to make sure everyone gets there and figures it out
and has a nice socially time.
No, because obviously Zoom socials at hybrids are very important to me, but if I'm attending
a convention virtually, I just make sure they happen even if they're not on the programme
and not part of the plan. But obviously, if I'm attending a convention in person, I'm
not going to spend hours on Zoom unless I find myself stuck in my hotel room. But I
wasn't actually stuck in my hotel room with Covid for very long and I was quite busy.
So I did think, I mean, I've been to that hotel before, I've never actually stayed in
that hotel. I treated myself to an actual room in the hotel, which was nice, except
for the weird, my personal round. Why do the hotel rooms not have any draws in? Who decided
to get weird nightstands with tripod legs?
This hotel room I'm currently in also does not. It is in fashion, Liz, draws for idiots,
shelves and hangers are in vogue. And whoever decided that, oof.
I mean, our room, which was a suite in the Hilton, did not have, it's not that it didn't
have draws, because I think not having draws is a great idea. The problem with draws is
that people leave their stuff in them. But if you have shelves that fulfil the function
of draws, that's still a lot better than not having them. But their view seemed to be that
your entire storage would be the rack that you put your suitcase on. And because our
car was so full, our suitcases were actually just packing cubes. So we didn't have anything.
If we'd had shelves that would have been something.
I would accept shelves. I mean...
This room has two shelves and room for about hanging 20 pieces of clothes, which is, I
mean I can hang all my t-shirts up, but I gotta be honest, usually I keep them in a
folded pile, and I imagine I am not atypical. Or I am atypical in many ways, but not in
this particular one. I can't imagine a circumstances in which I tag up a t-shirt really.
When there's no draws or shelves, that's when you hang a t-shirt. No, I just leave
them at an orderly pile on the floor, Liz. Oh yeah, I don't put my clothes on the floor.
Oh no, I mean I've got standards. Yeah. I mean I also bought a lot of clothes when
I was there, so I did really want somewhere to kind of sort them and stash them until
I took them home. But otherwise, I think that is a nice hotel. I think it is one of my favourite
of the EasterCon hotels we've been to recently, just because it's big. I never had to queue
for programme rooms. There was just tons of space in Italy, all of them. The corridor
is a big. It's not as bad as some of the others. You can have a nice big dealer's room.
It's not too difficult to get to. It's in walking distance of a mainline train station.
In Italy, you have to walk through the NEC, which may be full of 40,000 people who all
want to play Call of Duty. But...
On the way back to the train station, on the last night I had to walk through the NEC
and they wanted to check my bag. I was like, "What happens if you don't line my bag?"
I'm not walking round. I'm going through to the train station. And I got very grumpy.
So yeah, I don't like having to have a random man check in my bag so I can walk to a train
station without having to go round the way that takes three times as long. But that is
a minor complaint in general, but I mean it was very well connected and I quite like it
as a venue for the EastCon in general.
Anything else people want to say? We should probably say the programme was amazing. Well
done, see.
Oh yes, no. The programme was really good. The catch-up was really good. The hybrid was
really good. The real ale I quite liked. The port was good.
I liked the real ale. It wasn't as good as it could have been, but it was pretty bloody
good and it was a lot better than last time or the time before that when we'd been in
that hotel. So yay.
However, seven quits, seven pounds for a pint. My brain cannot process this.
Yep, so that was a lot, but my theory was that people would grumble but they would pay
it and that seems to be correct. Caroline was very worried that we wouldn't meet our food
and beverage and...
And John Dodd was like, "Oh Caroline, you do not need to worry. We passed it off Friday
evening." I mean, I think a lot of people ate in the hotel as well.
Oh, the food trucks. The food trucks were great. Did the food trucks count towards your
food and drinks, Ben? Yes.
Ah, okay.
Ha ha. The life hack. That is very clever.
Food trucks on the real ale and all of the hotels bar stuff. So all the... I'm pretty
sure that all of what was it called insomnia people who were staying in the hotel and who
were drinking and eating in the Hilton bar in the evenings, of whom they were quite
a lot all-couted to our food and beverage spend. Because there was no way to differentiate
that from a convention spend, right?
No. No, yeah, no, it's fair enough.
I think I drank fewer pints because they were seven quid and also they were nice. I didn't
think the convention specific beer was very nice, but the other ones were nice. But I
don't know if I'm out of touch or what, but seven pounds.
That was the old store podcast and it's goodbye from me.
It's goodbye from me. It's goodbye from me.
So I don't know if this is something that you guys will appreciate, but Caroline Mullen
has just messaged me to say, "Allison, are you all right? You haven't posted anywhere
on anything since this morning."
Have we been podcasting so long that people are worried about you?
Yes. We've been podcasting for three hours.
This is a savage indictment of how permanently online you are and also how long we have been
doing this.
We have been doing it a long time.
Yeah.
Team music for this episode was Fanfare for Space by Kevin MacLeod in Com